>>> THERE'S MORE BREAKING NEWS
AFTER A TENSE DAY.
JANUARY 6th TYPE OF ATTACK
RUNNING HIGH.
CAPITOL POLICE SAY A MAN
CLAIMING TO HAVE A BOMB POSED AN
HOURS' LONG STANDOFF.
FORTUNATELY THERE WAS NO BOMB.
WHAT WAS ON HIS MIND AS MUCH AS
CAN BE GLEANED FROM HIS SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTINGS.
MORE NOW FROM CNN'S RYAN NOBLES.
>> Reporter: IT STARTED AROUND
OR ABOUT 9:00 THURSDAY MORNING.
49-YEAR-OLD FLOYD RAY ROSE BERRY
ENTERED WASHINGTON, D.C., IN A
BLACK PICKUP TRUCK LOOKING TO
CAUSE TROUBLE.
>> I'M PARKED UP HERE ON THE
SIDEWALK.
>> HE SETTLED ON A SPOT IN FRONT
OF THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS
DIRECTLY ACROSS FROM THE U.S.
CAPITOL AND CLAIMED TO ANYONE
THAT WOULD LISTEN THAT HIS TRUCK
HAD A BOMB.
>> HEY, CALL THE POLICE AND TELL
THEM TO COME OUT HERE AND CLEAR
THE CAPITOL.
TELL THEM TO CLEAR THE CAPITOL.
>> HE QUICKLY GOT THE ATTENTION
OF CAPITOL POLICE.
THEY BEGAN TO CLEAR THE AREA.
AT 9:43.
USCP RESPONDING TO A SUSPICIOUS
VEHICLE NEAR THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
PLEASE STAY AWAY FROM THIS AREA.
THEN AT 9:54, LESS THAN AN HOUR
AFTER HE ARRIVED, THEY SENT THIS
MESSAGE TO STAFFERS ON THE HILL
TELLING THEM, AMONG OTHER
THINGS, IF YOU ARE IN A PUBLIC
SPACE, FIND A PLACE TO HIDE OR
SEEK COVER.
THAT BEGAN A LONG AND TENSE
STANDOFF BETWEEN ROSEBERRY AND
POLICE.
ONE THAT WOULD INCLUDE AN
EVACUATION AND LOCKDOWN OF
BUILDINGS ACROSS A THREE-BLOCK
RADIUS AS POLICE ATTEMPTED TO
WAIT ROSEBERRY OUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
LOOKS TO ME LIKE I'M GETTING
READY TO MAKE A PHONE CALL.
>> Reporter: HE LIVE STREAMED
HIS GRIEVANCES ON FACEBOOK
PROMISING A REVOLUTION, CALLING
OUT PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> I'M JUST WARNING YOU, BIDEN,
DON'T PULL THE TRIGGER ON THIS
TRUCK BECAUSE I'M NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
>> Reporter: HE DEMANDED BIDEN
RESIGN AND COMPLAINED ABOUT THE
NATION'S IMMIGRATION POLICY AND
RESPONSE IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT'S MY LAND.
IT'S YOUR LAND.
WE'RE THE PEOPLE.
TAKING A STAND.
GOT ALL THEM PENOPLE DYING IN
AFGHANISTAN.
ALL THEM KIDS BEING RAPED.
JUST LET THE TALIBAN RUN RIGHT
THROUGH.
>> HE ALSO SHOWED THE INSIDE OF
HIS TRUCK FILLED WITH LOOSE
CHANGE HE CLAIMED WOULD BE LOOSE
SHRAPNEL.
HE WARNED IF POLICE ATTEMPTED TO
SHOOT HIM TO END THE STANDOFF,
HIS TRUCK WOULD EXPLODE.
A LATER ASSESSMENT OF THE
TRUCK'S CONTENTS REVEALED THERE
WAS NO BOMB BUT WHAT POLICE
DESCRIBED AS BOMB-MAKING
MATERIALS.
THROUGHOUT THE ORDEAL CAPITOL
POLICE USED INVENTIVE WAYS TO
ATTEMPT TO QUELL THE SITUATION.
>> WE TRIED TO NEGOTIATE WITH
MR. ROSENBERRY.
WE TRIED TO DO THAT WITH A WHITE
BOARD WRITING MESSAGES BACK AND
FORTH.
WE USED A ROBOT TO GET A
TELEPHONE DOWN TO HIM BUT HE
WOULD NOT USE THE TELEPHONE.
>> Reporter: EVENTUALLY FIVE
HOURS AFTER IT BEGAN, ROSEBERRY
GAVE UP.
>> HE GAVE UP AND DID NOT RESIST
AND OUR FOLKS WERE ABLE TO TAKE
HIM INTO CUSTODY WITHOUT
INCIDENT.
>> Reporter: HIS PRECISE MOTIVES
REMAIN UNCLEAR BUT BASED ON HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA MONOLOGS, HE HAD A
BIG ANGST.
HIS SON TOLD CNN HIS FATHER TOOK
MUCH MORE OF AN INTEREST IN
POLITICS.
MAN, HE DOESN'T LIKE CHANGE, I
RECKON.
HIS FATHER TOLD HIM, QUOTE, I'M
STICKING UP FOR MY COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO GET THE COUNTRY BACK
TO THE WAY IT WAS.
>> RYAN NOBLES JOINS US NOW FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
SO I'M WONDERING WHAT YOUR SENSE
IS?
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE AFRAID OF WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th.
HE WAS SORT OF SPEAKING THE
LANGUAGE OF INSURRECTION AND
STUFF.
CLEARLY HE WAS MAKING IT ALL UP
ABOUT THE BOMB.
WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF HOW THAT
FEAR IMPACTED THE REACTION
TODAY?
>> Reporter: ANDERSON, I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY DOUBT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE ON JANUARY 6th AND
THE CONTINUING RHETORIC ALL OVER
SOCIAL MEDIA RIGHT NOW JUST MAKE
THESE INCIDENTS EVEN MORE
SERIOUS THAN THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN PRIOR TO JANUARY 6th.
THERE'S NO DOUBT LAW ENFORCEMENT
WOULD HAVE TAKEN THIS SITUATION
SERIOUSLY, BUT WHEN YOU GO TO
THE BROADER CAPITOL HILL
COMMUNITY, THE STAFFERS,
JOURNALISTS, PEOPLE WHO WERE UP
HERE, THEY HEAR OF REPORTS OF A
SUSPICIOUS PACKAGE OR VEHICLE
AND ASSUME IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE QUICKLY BRUSHED AWAY.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN ANYMORE.
EVERYONE TREATS EVERY INCIDENT
LIKE THIS VERY SERIOUSLY.
WHEN YOU COUPLE IT WITH A LIVE
STREAM OF THIS INDIVIDUAL
RANTING ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT,
SPECIFICALLY THE PRESIDENT, THAT
JUST RAISES THE ANXIETY LEVEL
EVEN HIGHER.
THERE'S JUST NO DOUBT THAT THE
WORLD CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY FOR
THE PEOPLE